[Music]
all right let's go to alicia in los
angeles hey alicia what's going on
hi dr john thank you so much for taking
my call thank you for calling i'm a huge
fan of you of you oh my gosh so what's
up how's it going
it's going okay um so my 31 year old
boyfriend was previously married okay
and i'm wondering how to navigate i
guess conversations and expectations
about his old wedding photos and photos
with his ex um which are still fairly
prominent
on his social
media he's taking them down but just all
over you know family and and friends and
it's not just
you know if you do a deep dive you can
find photos of anything i mean dave
ramsey says that
the devil but but i mean it's right
there when you click
on it so regarding his mom and his dad
does he have kids
no no kids okay
oh so his parents still have these
photos up
correct
okay
does he still have photos up in his
house
he's got one framed collage with her in
it um you know they were high school
sweethearts so they've got over 10 years
of history
and
i'm fine with you know a prom photo of
your ex-girlfriend but i feel like in
this case that's that's his ex-wife so
for me it
it impacts me a little bit more um oh
alicia you're not gonna like my answer
okay here's the thing i hear it i can do
one of two things i can super lie to you
and it would be way more fun for me or i
can just tell you the truth which one do
you want
absolutely the truth
okay
so how long have you been dating this
dude
a year but we recently went ring
shopping
gross okay curious so you went ring
shopping
okay so you say like you look him in the
eye and you get all like fluttery and
you say i love you and things like that
y'all are there
yes we are there uh-huh and is is he
the one you're choosing
absolutely
okay so you're in on this dude
i am okay
so
[Laughter]
i'm trying to be nice because you sound
so lovely
um
here's the thing you're marrying her too
and
she's a part of his life
she's his high school sweetheart she was
his wife
they've got a decade in together and one
of the things that's going to be so
tempting and so frustrating
is that you're going to always know that
she has 10 more years with him than you
do
and you're gonna have to let that go
or you're gonna drown the relationship
in
in competition a competition you can't
catch up with
your job isn't to be the a better wife
or the better one or the prettier one or
the
one who like that when you when you're
when you try to get into that lane you
put him in a situation that he can't
possibly win
you force his family into this weird
thing
my guess is eat one of two things either
he screwed up and they still like her my
parents like my wife more than me there
is no question about that
right
and my mom has even said as such like
just just so we're all clear if i ever
left my wife she's able to go stay with
them i am not like so we've had that
conversation that will fade over time
right so who knows what's in their heart
and head if they're making a move if
this is like a middle finger to you
or they're just 111 years old and they
don't know how to take old photos like
what you know what i mean like some some
parents aren't that savvy
if they're not they're not
okay
so they are not fans of her whatsoever
um she
decided to end the marriage kind of
shortly in due to differences in
finances and not wanting to start a
family with him okay um so
to them you know she broke his heart and
you know we've talked about it many
times so
they're not huge fans so okay i'm just a
little perplexed as to why okay why when
i click on it that's like the first
thing that pops up still i think it's
more because they're a little more
archaic and haven't gone to updating the
photos
as a person my wife tells me my wife
tells me all the time like i was born in
the wrong century so the last thing i
would think to do is to go change a
photo on the internet
that's just me and
so what i would do if i was you
is let the imaginary internet world be
the imaginary internet world who cares
okay and if it makes you nutty don't
click on it don't go to their pages
and at some point when you're engaged or
you're married and they say why don't
you ever comment on our post you could
say
oh gosh because that girl's still on
there i don't want to see her and you
can laugh about it and they'll go oh my
goodness does that make sense
it's it's the spirit you're going to
bring to this thing
and it is this she is a part of his life
forever
she is
and you've got to be okay with that
and
she's not a part of she is not his wife
anymore you're gonna be
and so you've got to rest in that
assurance that he picked you
ugh y'all are ring shopping you he
picked you yeah you won you won okay
does that make sense
that makes sense and you cannot compete
against her
that's not an event
that's something that just gonna make
you nuts and make him nuts does that
make sense
oh yeah and it has been mm-hmm it's hot
on
here's a cool thing you can do two
things number one
take this poor little boy like i did
that he's not he's a grown old 31 year
old man
take him out to dinner and say
i have been trying to size myself up
against your ex-wife i'm not doing that
anymore i love you and we're into this
thing and i know that
and he's going to be weirded out he's
going to have moments when he thinks
you're just going to break his heart
because it's already happened to him
he's gonna have moments when he misses
her
he's gonna have moments where there's a
ten-year-old inside joke that he's gonna
lean over to tell you and realize oh you
don't know that joke
that because they went to high school
together does that make sense
and you've gotta go it's not about me
cause he loves me and he's i'm i'm his
husband
and spending time trying to go back and
scorch the race to all that it's just
gonna just melt the guy
right okay
this is gonna be tough but you're gonna
have to be a grown-up about it you're
marrying a guy that's divorced okay so
you're marrying all of him and he's
probably gonna be an amazing husband
because he knows what heartbreak feels
like and he knows what attention feels
like is that fair
that is fair yes yeah so can you do that
can you oh i i told you two things
number one just take him out and say
dude i've been competing and i'm sorry
and i'm gonna stop doing that i'm just
gonna stop bringing her up
and um
the second thing is this
i want you to write down on a piece of
paper the things you
feel in competition with her about
okay
she's pretty
um she's hilarious um
she was really smart she had a good job
she made a bajillion dollars she
whatever whatever when you line yourself
up because i know you do that i still do
that to my wife's old boyfriends and
we've been together like 25 years i mean
it still happens
and by the way here's how i know my wife
and i have talked about um i had a
girlfriend in high school that is still
a close friend to this day
and she said
for the rest of my life she will always
have five years on me does that make
sense we've been married almost two
decades and it's that little thing in
the back she's just like ugh she's got
five years on me and of course it's it's
like one of those half jokes but half
kind of that's kind of true too and so
here's what you want you to write down
the things you compare then once you put
in a piece of paper i want you to mail
them to me
and when you put them in the mail that
is you saying i'm done i'm letting it go
i'm finished with it okay
okay it's gonna be a process that you do
and if you want to get a girlfriend
together and you'll do it together and
y'all can be
mean and ugly
all those things whatever whatever you
need to do write it down and mail it to
me and just say i'm putting it down i'm
done i'm sitting it down
is that fair okay
yes i will definitely do that if you
don't think you can not compete with her
don't marry this boy
because you're going to make yourself
miserable you're going to make him
miserable and your chance of success for
your relationship is going to be very
low
okay okay
okay now i'm going to tell you the other
answer okay the the lie answer
let's hear it now that we got that one
out of the way
forget her dude you should call hit her
and just be like you ruined it and i've
got him like do that is that cool i
don't know i don't know what like i
don't have a good go girl speech like in
my heart but that was the best i could
do
have you talked to her
no no i've never
i've never we ran into her once
coincidentally on her birthday
in the city that they grew up in but did
you size her up immediately
no i didn't i didn't know it was her i
was very confused yeah it was yes you
did you knew right away
you knew instantly because he went
up
she was in a group so i didn't i didn't
see her right away it was on the water
we were yeah we were out in the water
and
anyway it was it was a very awkward
situation
so here's what i want you to do as much
as you can as soon as you feel awkward
lean into it
lean into it and laugh even if it's
awkward and you look at him and go
that's awkward or at some point he may
call you the wrong name
go well that was awkward weirdo does
that make sense has that happened yeah
no not yet
not yet oh you are so geared up for war
let it go
let it go
you won you won you won
okay
you're marrying him he chose you you won
let her go
let her go there's something in when
you're working through um anxiety
there's um
one of the things we do sometimes when
working with folks who have phobias is
this progressive desensitization
where let's say someone's got a phobia
about snakes and uh
so they may have you draw a picture of a
snake with a crayon and you're just
trying to put you in this position and
ultimately we're leading to we're going
to show you a picture of a snake and
feel your body and then we're going to
show you a video of a snake i want you
to feel your body is your heart rate
racing we're gonna we're gonna do this
over and over again until you can see a
video of a snake and your heart rate
doesn't take off on you ultimately this
leads to you're gonna hold a snake we're
gonna take you to the zoo we're gonna
give you one right we're gonna get over
this phobia so maybe you do that with a
friend maybe you get a picture of her
and you just see it and then you get all
fired up and angry and mad
and then uh over time eventually you're
just like whatever yeah she's part of
his past
she's part of his past
but he's lucky to have you he's lucky to
have you
just
hey put him in the put him in the mail
put him in the mail and send them to me
i can't wait to get him hey she is right
that facebook is the devil
absolutely yeah and but yeah don't go
don't go
on your loved one's parents facebook
page that should just be a rule i'm
gonna put that on a john doloni t-shirt
don't go to your
husband or wife's parents facebook page
the only thing that's gonna be on that
stuff is sadness and like
weird conspiracy theory links and stuff
like that so yeah stay away good call
good call